[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض نبداها بالعناوين
الصراع في بخموت يشتد وبولندا تعلن تزويد
كييف بعشر دبابات اضافيه
ترفع الجلسه الى يوم
21/22 مارس 2023
ازمه السلطتين في الكويت تستمر رفع جلسه
البرلمان ونواب يصفون تعطيل الجلسات
بالعبث
رياض تبدا رحله التقييم نحو اكسبو 2020
دوري يصل العاصمه ويعقد اجتماعات مكثفه
في الرابعه
روشن تعلن عن مشروع وارث ثاني مشاريعها
السكنيه في الرياض الفاء وحده وثلاثه عشر
الف مستفيد
المنتدى الدولي للترفيه في الرياض مختصون
من انحاء العالم يناقشون مستقبل القطاع
والتحدياته
نبدا من تطورات الحرب الاوكرانيه حيث
يتواصل القتال في شرق البلاد خاصه في باخ
موت المحوريه في اقليم في هذا السياق
اعلنت سلطات دانياسكا المواليه لروسيا ان
القوات الروسيه اصبحت تسيطر على نصف مدينه
بخموت وقالت دينيس بوشيلين المسؤول
الموالي لروسيا في دانياتسك لوكاله سين
القوات الروسيه المستمره في التقدم
بالمدينه ومن جهته قال قائد قوات الروسيه
ان القوات الاوكرانيه تحسنت مواقعها في
المحورين الشمالي والغربي من بخمه
وزير الدفاع الروسي سيرجي جوا ان السيطره
على مدينه باك موت ستسمح للقوات بمواصله
هجومها في عمق دفاعات القوات الاوكرانيه
واضاف شويغو ان الغرب زاد من وتيره
امدادات الاسلحه الى كييف في اطار ما
اسماه بالاستراتيجيه الامريكيه لكسر روسيا
بقوه السلاح مشيرا الى ان ذلك لن يؤدي الى
نجاح القوات الاوكرانيه
مراسل العربيه رائد الاغبر رائد مرحبا بك
ما هو جديد التطورات الميدانيه في ساحات
المعارك خصوصا في ضخمه
مساء الخير مره اخرى خالد بالفعل معركه
باخموت هي اكثر سخونه والتي تظهر تصريحات
متواتره كل ساعه حول ما يحدث في باقمت كما
اسلفت وزير الدفاع الروسي قال بان ما بعد
السيطره على باقمت سيفتح الباب
للدخول الى المدن الكبرى وهي كراماتورسكو
قال ايضا بان القوات الروسيه سيطرت على ما
نسبه اربعين بالمئه من مدينه يعني وهذا
التصريحيه يتناقض مع ما قاله
قالته السلطات هنا ان نصف المدينه اصبحت
تحت سيطره قوات فاغنف كما انه اضاف بان 11
الف قتيلا خسرتهم القوات الاوكرانيه في
باخمت خلال فبراير الماضي طبعا المثير
للاهتمام
قائد قوات فاجنر يفغينيا بروجين وكعادته
اطلق انتقادات لتصريحات وزير الدفاع
الروسي سير جيشو يقول بريجوجن بان من
المبكر الحديث عن ما بعد باخمت لان
المعارك ما زالت مستمره وفي باخمت اصعب
المعارك التي تخوضها قوات فاجنر يقول ايضا
بان القوات الاوكرانيه لا تستسلم بسهوله
بل يموتون جماعات وانهم يعني يستسلمون
كملاذ اخير اذا فقدوا كل الطرق للمقاومه
بل هم يدافعون عن المدينه بكل ما استطاعوا
كما انه اضاف بان هناك تعزيزات كما تحدثنا
في الصباح خالد تعزيزات في المحور الشمالي
والغربي في اربع مدن تعزيزات كبيره وعن
عشرات الالاف اضاف بان يعني ضاربا مثلا
بانه من
المبكره الحديث عن استخدام جلد الدب قبل
اصطياده يجب ان نقتل الدب اولا ثم نفكر
بماذا نفعل في جلد هذا الدب بالفعل ما زال
يقول بان الامدادات العسكريه بالذخيره لم
تصل حتى الان وهذا سيعرقل تقدم القوات
الروسيه اضاف بريغوجين بان ما قاله
وزير الدفاع الروسي صحيح بخصوص اكثر من
عشره الاف قتيل في شهر فبراير الماضي
ويقول بان عمليات التنظيف التي دائما يعني
تقول عنها وزاره الدفاع ربما تكون هي
لترتيب الملابس ويعني اجتياح الشوارع
فارغه انه يؤكد ان من يقاتلون على الارض
يعلمون ما هي المعارك وما صعوباتها بالفعل
هناك انتقادات وتباين كبير ما بين
التصريحات من وزاره الدفاع ومن قوات فاجنر
القوات الخاصه لكن يعني الفريقين يقاتلون
من اجل تقديم انجازات خالد للكرملين
الروسي هذه قاعده وبالفعل ما زالت المعارك
مستعره هنا في المحور الشرقي كما اسلفت في
يعني في مناطق مختلفه ليس في باقمت مدينه
افديفكا تشهد ايضا معارك عنيفه من قبل
القوات الافخاذيه التي تقاتل هناك وطوقت
المدينه على شكل مثلث يعني من جانبين
وتحاول اقتحام المدينه وهناك اسلحه متطوره
تستخدمها القوات الروسيه هناك الحديث عن
قنبله
القنبله تزن 1500 كيلوغرام تحدث تدميرا
كبيرا في المدينه هناك ايضا اسلحه متطوره
كثيره دخلت في نطاق العمليات العسكريه منذ
مطلع هذا العام شكرا جزيلا لك من دانيتك
مراسل العربيه رائد الاخضر
مدينه كان يقتلها 70 الف نسمه قبل اشتداد
المعارك
الرئاسه الاوكرانيه
5400 اوكراني فقط لا يزالون في المدينه
الجنود الاوكرانيون المتحصنون في خنادق
مؤمل
الروس يحاصرون ضخمه من ثلاث جهات باستثناء
المحور الغربي
الجنود الروسي يتحصلون بخنادق بمحيط
المدينه لتجنب القصف الاوكراني
الرئيس الاوكراني اتفقت مع القاده
العسكريين على استمرار الدفاع عن ضخمه
وزير الدفاع الامريكي ضخمت لها رمزيه لكن
سقوطها باليد روسيا لن يغير مجرى الحرب
اكد وزير الدفاع الالماني باريس بيستوريوس
ان المانيا ليس لديها اي نقص في معدات
دبابات لوبارد مضيفا بان المشكله كانت فقط
بتاخر الصيانه والاصلاح وانه يجري العمل
على حل الامر
ليس لدينا اي نقص في معدات دبابات علي
الاختلاف مع ذلك بوضوح شديد كان لدينا
تاخير في الصيانه والاصلاح ويجري العمل
على ذلك لكن الاصول التي تمكنا من تجديدها
هي في فرقه العمل المشتركه ذات الجاهزيه
العاليه والامر ليس بذلك السوء كما قرات
هذا الصباح هذه اداره طبيعيه للموارد
عندما تتعطل المركبات او تصعب صيانتها
بسرعه كافيه يتم استبدالها بمركبات اخرى
ذات قيمه متساويه والتي تضمن مع المركبات
الموجوده امكانيه انجاز المهمه ولا شك في
ذلك
اعلن رئيس بيلاروسيا الكسندر لوكاشينكو
اعتقال اكثر من 20 شخصا متواطئين مع
المخابرات الاوكرانيه والامريكيه في
محاوله لتخريب طائره الروسيه باحد
المطارات البيلاروسيه واوضح لوكاشينكو ان
الطائره تعرضت لاضرار سطحيه فقط في الهجوم
الذي تم باستخدام طائره بدون طيار صغيره
حسبما افادت وكاله الانباء البيلاروسيه
مشددا ان اوكرانيا لن تنجح في جر بلاده
للدخول في الحرب
اكد وزير الدفاع الامريكي ان زيارته غير
المعلنه للعراق تهدف الى تعزيز الشراكه
الاستراتيجيه وقال وزير الدفاع الامريكي
انه يؤمن بضروره دمج العراق مع شركاء في
المنطقه مشيرا الى ان القوات الامريكيه
موجوده في العراق بطلب من الحكومه كما قال
استناكد بوعيده وصوله الى بغداد في زياره
غير معلنه ان الجانبين يتحركان نحو عراق
اكثر امنا واستقرارا وسياده وقال مسؤول
دفاعي امريكي لرايترز ان الزياره التي لم
يتم الاعلان عنها مسبقا تهدف الى اظهار
التزام واشنطن بالحفاظ على وجودها العسكري
في العراق وان الولايات المتحده مهتمه على
نطاق واسع بشراكه الاستراتيجيه مع الحكومه
العراقيه
القوات الامريكيه مستعده للبقاء في العراق
وذلك بطلب من الحكومه العراقيه وستنشط هذه
القوات في مجالات غير قتاليه على صعد
المساعده والمشوره لدعم حرب العراق ضد
الارهاب هذه مهمه حاسمه ونحن فخورون بدعم
شركائنا العراقيين لكن يجب ان يكون
التعاون تحت شرط السلامه والامن لانجاز
هذا العمل
في رابع بعد الفصل فريقوا عمل خارجي يناقش
اخر مراحل ربط وتبادل المخالفات المروريه
بين دول المج
لس
اهلا بكم من جديد اصدر امير قطر الشيخ
تميم بن حمد ال ثاني قرارا باعاده تشكيل
مجلس الوزراء تضمن القرار تعيين وزير
الخارجيه الشيخ محمد بن عبد الرحمن هل
ثاني رئيسا لمجلس الوزراء وذلك بعد قبول
استقاله رئيس الوزراء السابق الشيخ خالد
بن خليفه الثاني واجرى ايضا تعيين الشيخ
خليفه بن حمد بن خليفه الثاني وزيرا
للداخليه
ازمه السلطتين في الكويت مستمره حيث رفع
رئيس مجلس الامه احمد السعدون جلسه اليوم
الثلاثاء الى يوم الحادي والعشرين من مارس
الجري بعد اعتذار الحكومه عن حضور الجلسه
على الاستعدون رفع الجلسه بان تشكيل
الحكومه لا يزال قيد المشاورات بعد تكليف
الشيخ احمد النواف بتشكيله هذا الاجراء
دفع بعض النواب الى وصف استمرار تعطيل
الجلسات من قبل الحكومه بالعبث الذي يجب
ان ينتهي على حد وصفهم مع استمرار ايضا
الازمه عدم انعقاد جلسات المجلس بسبب
اعتذار الحكومه كشفت صحيفه القبسانيه بعض
النواب الاعلان عن البقاء في مبنى المجلس
حتى انتهاء وقت الجلسات احتجاجا على الرفع
المتكرر
للجلسات
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
يوم امس استلمت الرساله التاليه
بعد اتصال ايضا من الاخ وزير الدوله لشؤون
مجلس الامه
الرساله تتضمن بصدور الامر الاميري بتعيين
سموه الشيخ احمد نواف الاحمد الصباح رئيسا
لمجلس الوزراء
وتكليفه بترشيح اعضاء الوزاره الجديده
ونظرا لان سموه بصدد المشاورات لترشيح
اعضاء الوزاره الجديده
تتقدم الحكومه بالاعتذار عن عدم حضور جلسه
مجلس الامه المقرر عقدها يوم الثلاثاء
والاربعاء
الموافقين سبعه
وثمانيه الفين
والان على الرغم من وجود النصاب ترى حتى
في الجلسه الماضيه كان في نصاب كان لما
اعلنت كان اخوان داخلين موجودين وكان في
نصاب الرقم موجود النصاب
ترفع الجلسه الى يوم
21/22 مارس 2023
بالكويت تنضم الينا الصحفي محمد السبتي
سيد محمد حياك الله معي في نشره الرابعه
لا جديد في هذه الازمه ما زالت مستمره
ازمه السلطتين التشريعيه والتنفيذيه في
الكويت
هذه المره هل ما ساقه رئيس المجلس من
مبررات حول تاجيل انعقاد جلسه المجلس هي
دستوريه
هو هذا خلاف دستوري قديم متجدد هل تنعقد
جلسات مجلس الامه
بوجو بعدم وجود الحكومه هل يشترط لصحه
انعقاد هذه الجلسات تمثيل الحكومه ولو
بوزير واحد ام ان الشرط الوحيد لانعقاد
الجلسه هو وجود النصاب هذا خلاف دستوري
قديم منذ يعني من الستينات ويقع الخلاف
بين بعض اعضاء مجلس الامه عن مدى صحه
انعقاد الجلسات بعدم تمثيل الحكومه اليوم
بعض النواب يرون انهم يعملون هذا الراي
الذي يقول بصحه انعقاد الجلسات حتى مع
غياب الحكومه لان هناك غياب متعمد
قد يكون له اسبابه عند الحكومه لكنهم
يرونه متعمد ويرون ان الحكومه تعطل اعمال
المجلس فلذلك ينحون الى الاخذ بالراي الذي
يقول بص حه انعقاد هذه الجلسات حتى لو لم
تجد الحكومه الا ان هذا الخلاف ليس بجديد
بل هو قديم وقديم جدا يعني طيب هذه المره
هل هو غياب متعمد من قبل الحكومه هل
بالفعل الحكومه هي من تعط العمل المجلس
كما يقول النواب
او بعض النواب لا الحقيقه ولا الانصاف ولا
دفاع عن الحكومه الحكومه تغيبت عن جلسات
مجلس الامه لاسباب اظنها او يظنها كثير من
المراقبين انها مبرره هناك تعنت في
استخدام كثير من الصلاحيات والحقوق
المتاحه للنواب تجاه بعض الوزراء او تجاه
الحكومه ككل هذا التعنت تمثل في كثير من
الاستجوابات التي تتوالى على وزير بعد
وزير وعلى وزاره بعد وزاره دون ان تكون
هناك مبررات هذا التعنت في استخدام بعض
الصلاحيات المتاحه للنواب هو الذي ادى الى
يعني غياب هذه الحكومه اقرار بعض القوانين
التي ترى الحكومه انه لا مجال ابدا
لاقرارها كقانون اسقاط القروض مثلا
المجتمع الاقتصادي
الحكومي كثير من الفعاليات يرون كلها مجال
ابدا حتى في الخيال ان يفرض او يسن قانون
لاسقاط قروض المواطنين الا ان بعض اعضاء
مجلس الامه يتقدمون بمثل هذا المشروع
ويمرر من خلال لجنه الاقتصاديه ويعرض على
اعمال مجلس الامه فتجد الحكومه نفسها امام
خيارين اما ان تواجه برد هذا القانون عن
طريق صاحب السمو امير البلاد او بدخول
مفاوضات ترى انه لا جدوى من مثل هذه
الاعمال هذا التعنت هو الذي ادى الى غياب
الحكومه لهذه الجلسات سواء بعد استقالتها
او قبل استقالتها عشره نائبا كويتيا اعلن
واعتزامهم تفعيل الادوات الدستوريه
والمسائله السياسيه اذا تجاوز رئيس
الوزراء المده الزمنيه المقرره وهي لتشكيل
الوزاره وهي اسبوعين وكذلك نواب قالوا
بانهم سيعلنون الاعتصام في قاعه عبد الله
السالم نائبان ايضا دعا رئيس مجلس الامه
الى التخلي عن رئاسه الجلسه المقبله لمنح
الفرصه لعقد الجسدون حضور الحكومه كل هذه
التطورات لا تسير الازمه برا
الحقيقه ساقولها ويعني في قلبي غصه نحن
نعاود خظ المائي لننتجه منه زبده وما زلنا
منذ 60 سنه نجري عمليه خض الماء حتى ننتج
من هذه من عمليه الخفض زبدا والحقيقه ان
خف الماء لا ينتجه زبده بل خفض الحليب هو
الذي ينتج زبده كل هذه الاجراءات التي
ينوى اتخاذها استجواب رئيس مجلس الوزراء
الاعتصام داخل يعني مبنى البرلمان استجواب
بعض الوزراء التهديد غير هي عمليات تم
اتخاذها مرارا وتكرارا على مدى سنوات
طويله لم تاتي باي ناتج يجب ان نعترف بهذه
الحقيقه الحقيقه عندما نمارسه من عمليه
سياسيه عمليه فاشله جدا لا تاتي باي نتيجه
لا نريد ان نحدد من المسؤول اليوم نحن نقر
ان هذا النظام لا لم يعد يعني يصلح
للتطبيق العملي ثم ناتي الى تحديد تحميل
المسؤوليه على من لذلك اذا سالتني سيدي
الفاضل ما الجديد في خضم هذه الاجراءات
المنوى المزعم مع اتخاذها سواء من النواب
هو المشهد الان يعني الذي نعيشه هنا يختلف
الامر لانه كان سمو العهد الكويتي قد قدم
خطابا مختلفا هذه المره انه في حال
تكررت هذه الازمه فان هناك يعني
يعني ما سماها
ربما اجراءات صعبه قد تتخذ من قبل الكويت
لمعالجه هذه الازمه هل نسير بهذا الاتجاه
واذا كان الامر بهذا الشكل ماذا يعني
سموه للعهد باتخاذ قرارات صعبه كما قال او
مؤلمه
سوف اتكلم بلساني ما اتمنى او يتمناه بعض
يعني المراقبين نعم ان تكون هناك اجراءات
غير مسبوقه ما هي هذه الاجراءات الغير
مسبوقه ان نتوقف عن ممارسه العبث باسم
الديمقراطيه ما نمارسه منذ 60 سنه عبثا
نسميه ديموقراطيه الان يجب ان نتوقف هذا
التوقف قد يكون صعبا قد يكونوا كمن يحتسي
المر نحن اوهمنا انفسنا كمجتمع اننا نمارس
اعمالا ديموقراطيه الان يجب ان نقتنع يجب
ان نحتس المر ونقتنع ان هذه ليست
ديمقراطيه ان هذا عبثا اذا اتخذنا هذا
القرار بوقف هذا العبث ثم نبحث عن بديل
لكيفيه تسيير امورنا الواقفه العالقه امور
المجتمع كلها يعني عالقه منذ سنوات طويله
على يعني عمليه
لا تعمل لا تنتج شيئا والصغار والكبار
ينتظرون الصغير يكبر وهو ينتظر ان تنتج
هذه العمليه التي نوقن انها لا تنتج شيئا
اذا ما الحل الحل ان نواجه هذا الخطا الحل
ان نواجه انفسنا ان نواجه هذا الوهم الذي
عشناه الذي يعني ربينا عليه المجتمع لنقول
لهم ان مارسناه خطا وان هذا هو الصواب لعل
في التصريح يعني مشكله في مثل هذه المواقف
لكنني اقول وبكل صدق اننا بحاجه الى
مراجعه حقيقيه
لمفاهيمنا في هذه العمليه السياسيه التي
نسميها ديموقراطيه او خلينا نسميها انها
عمليه شكرا جزيلا لك الصحفي محمد السبتي
ضيفي من الكويت
استعرض ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان مع وفد المكتب الدولي للمعارض ملف
السعوديه لاستضافه معرض الرياض اكسبو 2030
وذلك خلال استقباله رئيس المكتب الدولي
للمعارض باتريك سبيكت والوفد المرافقه له
في العاصمه الرياض
وقبل ذلك عقدت بعثه المكتب الدولي للمعارض
اولى ورش العمل لتقييم ملف السعوديه
لاستضافه
الرياض ضمن اجراءات المكتب لتحديد الدوله
المستضيفه للمعرض وجرا خلال ورشه العمل
الاولى استعراض مقومات ترشح مدينه الرياض
الاستضافه المغرب والقيمه المضافه التي
ستقدمها نسخه المعرض في حال اختيار الرياض
لاستضافتها
تفاصيل اكثر عن ملف اكسبورياد 2030 مع
العنود العبدلي نتابع
اكس ثلاثين شاق وصعب هذا ما تتركه الرياض
جيدا مع العمل المستمر والمكثفه على ملف
الاستضافه منافسه من اربع مدن عالميه هي
موسكو في روسيا ومدينه بوسان الكوريه
الجنوبيه ومدينه روما الايطاليه واخيرا
مدينه اوديسا في اوكرانيا المدن الاربعه
ستنافس العاصمه السعوديه الرياض على الفوز
باستضافه اكسبو 2020
على ماذا تراهن الرياض ولي العهد السعودي
الامير محمد بن سلمان اكد التزام الرياض
بتقديم تجربه عالميه غير مسبوقه وهذا
اعلان السعوديه ووعدها لترشح استضافه او
لترشيح استضافه الرياض لمعرض اكسبو الدولي
اكتوبر 2030 هو موعد انطلاق المعرض الدولي
اكسبو ويستمر حتى ابريل من العام 2021
دعونا الان مشاهدينا نتعرف اكثر على ملف
الرياض لاستضافتها هذا الحدث اختار الفريق
المعني بالملف موقعا مميزا لمرض اكسبو في
شمال مدينه الرياض يمتد هذا الموقع على
مساحه سته ملايين متر مربع ويقع على بعد
اقل من عشر دقائق من مطار الملك خالد
الدولي ومن المتوقع ايضا مشاهدينا تسجيل
اربعين مليون زائر لموقع المعرض في حال
فوز الرياض بالاستضافه اضافه الى حضور
226 مشاركا ضمن اجنحه دوليه ومنظمات
عالميه ومشاركين غير رسميين التطور
التكنولوجي مشاهدينا وتاثيرات التغير
المناخي والازدهار للجميع تعبر عن مرتكزات
استضافه الرياض الحدث الذي تسعى من خلاله
الى تعزيز الحلول المستدامه والمرونه في
التحولات التي اشهدها العالم تتقدم الرياض
مشاهدينا بشكل سريع في قائمه المدن الاكثر
زياره في العالم سياحيا وكذلك ثقافيا من
خلال المواقع المتعدده
وسياسه التاشيرات المفتوحه ما يجعلها
جاهزه لاستضافه العالم
من رياض مراسل العربيه عبد المحسن الحربي
عبد المحسن مرحبا بك هل هناك اي معلومات
اضافيه ايضا عن عمل وفد المكتب الدولي
للمعرض هذا اليوم
نعم خالد بالفعل بدا هذا الوفد المكون من
المكتب الدولي للمعارض للقيام باعماله
وتحديدا ورش العمل واللقاءات التي بداها
منذ يوم الامس وستستمر حتى يوم الجمعه
القادم الجدول الزيارات حافل ومليء
باللقاءات بالمسؤولين والوزراء وكذلك كافه
الضلعين في هذا الملف سواء كان من كافه
القطاعات نحن نتحدث عن ان الوفد يركز على
ابرز مقومات المدينه من مختلف انحائي
المدينه تحدث عن قطاع النقل سيلتقي وسيزور
مترو الرياض ومشروع الحافلات وايضا عن
القطاعات الاخرى بنظام الفندقه وكافه
المقومات الاخرى للمدينه التي سيقوم بعمل
زيارات كبيره جدا خلال الايام القليله
القادمه في جدول
اعماله من ثم سيتم عقد مؤتمر صحفي في
نهايه زياره هذا الوفد يوم الجمعه مع
الرئيس التنفيذي لهنايا الملكيه لمدينه
الرياض في نهايه هذه الجوله من ثم من مقرر
ايضا سيكون هناك زيارات اخرى لهذا الوفد
للدول الاخرى المرشحه وسيتم الاعلان عن
الترشيح الملف في مايو القادم بعد ما
يقارب شهرين من الان خالد متوقع ان يتم
ترشيح رسميا هذه الزيارات التي يقومون بها
في السعوديه وفي الدول المنافسه يتحدث عن
الدول الاخرى من ثم بعد ذلك تبدا عمليه
التصويت في نوفمبر القادم وهي عمليه تصويت
سريه من الدول الاعضاء في هذا في هذا في
هذه المنظمه وفي الحقيقه كان هنالك عمل
دبلوماسي كبير جدا للسعوديه خلال السنتين
الماضيه من اكتوبر منذ اعلان الترشح رسميا
من قبل ولي العهد السعودي حتى الان ما
يقارب 80 دعم
وموافقه على التصويت من قبل الدول زارت
السعوديه او حتى السعوديه زارتها
للترشح ودعم السعوديه في ملفها للترشح في
اكسبو 2020 في نوفمبر القادم اذا هذه خطوه
ثانيه يقوم بها
تخطوها السعوديه نحو ملف استضافه 2030 بعد
زياره هذا الوافد والترشح رسميا من قبل
المكتب خالد شكرا جزيلا لك اذا من الرياض
مراسل العربيه عبد المحسن الحربي
نقش فريق العمل الخاص بربط المخالفات
المروريه في دول مجلس التعاون لدول الخليج
العربيه اخر مراحل عمليه الربط وتفعيل
تبادل المخالفات المروريه بدول المجلس
وتمشينها خلال الفتره القليله القادمه
تضمنت المناقشه الاخيره ملفات عده منها
ضروره توحيد الاجراءات وتبادلها بين
الاجهزه المروريه وفق اليات تعمل وتساهم
في الحد من وقوع الحوادث ومخالفه القواعد
المروريه في دول المجلس
في الرابعه بعد قليل قلت لك مشروع دار
خزامى السكني في شمال الرياض الاسعار تبدا
من 350 الف ريال
اهلا بكم من جديد في السعوديه اعلنت
مجموعه روشين المطور العقاري يعني قامت
مشروع وارث السكني الذي يعد ثاني مشاريعها
في العاصمه الرياض تقدر مساحه
بمليون واربعمائه الف متر مربع من المخطط
بناءه اكثر من 2000 وحده سكنيه على ارض
المشروع لاستيعاب ما يقرب 13 الف نسمه يقع
المشروع الجديد في حي الجنادريه شرق مدينه
الرياض ويتبع في تصميمه اسس ومبادئ
التخطيط والتصميم والمواصفات لمجتمعات
روشن السكنيه حول السعوديه شركه روشن
المملوكه لصندوق الاستثمارات بينت ان
الطاقه الشمسيه ستكون مصدرا رئيسيا
للكهرباء في هذا المشروع
ايضا في اخبار العقار اطلقت الشركه
السعوديه للاسكان مشروع دار الخزام احد
مشاريع المرحله الاولى من ضاحيه خزام في
مدينه الرياض لمستحقي الدعم السكني باسعار
تبدا من 350 الف ريال ويوفر مشروع دار
خزام 270 وحده سكنيه على مساحه تجاوزت 22
الف متر مربع بشقاق عصريه تم تصميمها وفق
اعلى معايير جوده الحياه وبمساحات سكنيه
تراوحت ما بين 139 الى 176 مترا مربعا
ياتي المشروع ضمن جهود تهدف الى توفير
مشاريع حيويه ذات طابع حضري ومميز داخل
الضواحي ومجتمعات متكامله الخدمات
والمرافق
نبقى في العاصمه السعوديه الرياضه التي
تحتضن ايضا اليوم وغدا المؤتمر الدوليه
للترفيه بمشاركه المنظمه الدوليه للوجهات
والمدن الترفيهيه واكثر من 24 شركه عالميه
وخمسه واربعين متحدثا عالميا في القطاع
شهد اليوم الاول من المنتدى استعراض
التجارب السعوديه في القطاع فضلا عن
تنظيمي جلسات حواريه تتعلق باداره عمليات
الالعاب الضخمه
بس العربيه انا واقفه عزيز ينضم الينا
الان من المنتدى الدولي للترفيه في الرياض
اهلا نواف ما هي مشاهداتك في المنتدى
نعم خالد اهلا بك انطلاقه مهمه للمنتدى
الدولي للترفيه الذي تنظمه الهيئه العامه
للترفيه بالشراكه مع المنظمه الدوليه
للوجهات والمدن الترفيهيه ربما يكون
الاعلان الابرز اليوم لرئيس المنظمه
جيباتسون الذي اعلن عن افتتاح مكتب او مقر
اقليمي للمنظمه في الشرق الاوسط ومن
المحتمل كثيرا ان يكون مقر المنظمه في
السعوديه منذ بدء المنتدى كان هناك العديد
من الجلسات التي تختص بقطاع الترفيه تطوير
القطاع الابتكارات الجديده في هذا القطاع
بمشاركه كبرى الشركات واربعه وعشرين شركه
عالميه متواجده معي الان عضو لجنه الترفيه
والثقافه في الغرفه التجاريه بالرياض محمد
الشثري اهلا وسهلا سيد محمد في البدايه
كيف سينعكس هذا المنتدى على القطاع الخاص
في الترفيه هنا طبعا اخوي نواف او اول شيء
اللي حاب اقوله ان احنا كاعضاء في منظمه
ايابا اللي هي المنظمه الدوليه للوجهات
والمراكز الترفيه احنا اعضاء يمكن من اكثر
من عشر سنوات يعني ما بدر في بالنا يوم
انه يكون حدثهم وحدث رئيسي بهالشكل يكون
جنبنا ويعني
في مدينتنا الرياض فيعني نقول اول شيء
الحمد لله على هالنعمه انه ربي يسخر وجاب
الممكن هذا الكبير اللي للقطاع اللي يعني
يعتبر
اكبر جهه تنظيميه لمصنعين ومزودين الخدمات
في قطاع الترفيه ومراكز الترفيه والوجهات
الترفيهيه طبعا انعكاسا بيكون لا شك
ايجابي وهو يصب في الاخير في مستهدفات
رؤيه سمو سيدي من ناحيه رفع جوده الحياه
في مملكتنا
والاكيد انه بيلامس كثير من الناس وفي وقت
يعني منظمه بهالحجم ما تجي الا بعد دراسه
السوق ومعرفه انه في فجوه كبيره محتاجه
مستثمرين محتاجه تعارض كل من يشغل هالقطاع
محليا ودوليا
لاشغال هالفجوه اللي موجوده احنا نقول ان
شاء الله الفجوه بدات تتناقص مع كثر
العروض اللي موجوده ترفيهيه والتركيز الان
تركيز كيف ليس كم فقط
نقول ان شاء الله ان الانعكاسات ايجابيه
احنا قاعدين نلامسها كقطاع خاص وكم ممثلين
في في الغرفه التجاريه وجميع الجهات
الحكوميه الان نشوفها تساهم لنفس لنفس
المستهدف كل الشكر لك السيد محمد اذا خالد
نعلم ان قطاع الترفيه في السعوديه يستهدف
الى الوصول باستثمارات تبلغ تسعه وستين
مليار دولار بحلول عام 2030 وبالتاكيد مع
هذا المنتدى والجهود في قطاع الترفيه خلال
السنوات المقبله ستصل بالاستثمارات الى
هذا الرقم وربما اعلى من هذا الرقم بحلول
عام 2030 شكرا جزيلا لك نوف عزيز مراسل
العربيه من المنتدى الدولي للترفيه
بالرياض
الى الرياض الان مع زياد عبيدات
[موسيقى]
شكرا خالد واهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام في
اياب دوره 16 مسابقه دوري ابطال اوروبا
لكره القدم يلتقي الليله تشيلسي الانجليزي
مع ضيفي بروسيا دورتموند الالماني وكانت
مباراه الذهاب بين الفريقين قد انتهت بفوز
دورتموند بهدف المقابل لا شيء وياتي
الفريق الانجليزيه من فوز على ليدز
يونايتد في الدوري المحلي يوم السبت
الماضي وفي المقابل يحتلب روسيا دورتموند
المركز الثاني في دوري بلاده متاخرا بفارق
الاهداف عن بايرن
يمكن للجميع رؤيه نتيجه الخصم في الدوري
الالماني هم يمرون بفتره رائعه الى حد
كبير يفوزون بالمباريات باستمرار اعتقد
انها عشر مباريات متتاليه وهذا يوضح لك
ماهيتهم كبريغ يهاجم يدافعون لديهم افراد
جيدون ومدرب جيد سامبل بريج سيكون مشتعلا
انا متاكد تماما وسنقدم كل شيء للفوز
بالمباراه والتاهل انها مباراه كبيره
وحماسيه فرصه للتاهل الى دور الثمانيه
وليله خاصه فيرج كل تفكير ينصب في محاوله
ان نكون ايجابيين ونحول المضي قدما والفوز
بالمباراه
لا اعرف اذا كانت اكبر مباراه في مسيرتي
ولا اهتم لان الامر لا يتعلق بي انه يتعلق
بفريقه بروسيا دورتموند وانا جزء من هذا
الفريق اتذكر اننا لعبنا ايضا في ربع
النهائي قبل عامين امام اشبيليه انها ايضا
مباراه مهمه جدا وبعد ذلك لعبنا امام
مانشستر سيتي اسف في ربع النهائي امام
مانشستر سيتي كانت ايضا مهمه للغايه هي
مباراه مهمه جدا بالنسبه لنا في النادي
ونريد ان نظهر انه يمكننا المنافسه على
هذا المستوى واننا على استعداد للقتال من
اجل ان نكون احد الفرق الثمانيه الاولى في
اوروبا ولكن في نهايه المطاف نريد فقط ان
نستحق ذلك واذا استحقينا التاهل سنكون
سعداء للغايه
وضمن الدوري نفسه لمسابقه دوري ابطال
اوروبا لكره القدم سيكون بنفيكا
البرتغاليه على موعد مع كلاب روج
البلجيكيه ونجح الفريق والبرتغالي بالفوز
ذهابا خارج ملعبه بهدفين دون مقابل ويحتل
صداره الدوري بفارق ثمان نقاط عن بورتو
صاحب المركز الثاني من جانبه يتبروج من
هزيمه ثقيله امام نادي اوستاند ضمن الدوري
البلجيكي لكره القدم
سحبت امس قرعه بطوله كاس الملك سلمان
للانديه العربيه لكره القدم في العاصمه
السعوديه الرياض وحلف المجموعه الاولى
الترجي التونسي الاتحاد السعودي والمتاهل
الثالث والشرطه العراقيه وفي المجموعه
الثانيه السد القطري الوداد المغربي
المتاهل الرابع والهلال السعودي المجموعه
الثالثه الزمالك المصري المتاهل الخامس
والنصر السعودي والمتاهل الثاني المجموعه
الرابعه ضمه شباب بلوزداد الجزائري الرجاء
المغربي والمتاهل السادس وكذلك المتاهل
الاول
تغلب الفتح على الهلال بهدفين مقابل هدف
واحد في مباراه مؤجله من الجوله الثامنه
عشره للدوري السعودي لكره القدم تفاصيل
هذه المباراه في التقرير التاليه
[موسيقى]
في الرياض من اجل اللحاق بركب المقدمه
الضيوف يبادرون بمهاجمه مرمى عبد الله
المعيوف من خلال محاولات جريئه بحثا عن
كسر نتيجه التعادل
[تصفيق]
هجمات الفتح منحت البرازيلي بطرس الوصول
الى مرمى الهلال غير ان حكم اللقاء الغى
الهدف بداع التسلل لمصلحه الهلال عند
المحاولات الهلاليه استمرت وعبد الله
الحمدان يفشل في تحويل الكره الى المرمى
الفرنسيه مدرب المنتخب السعودي يتابع
المباراه الفتح ينجح قبل انتهاء الشوط
الاول بخمس دقائق في احراز هدف التقدم عن
طريق الاسباني كريستيانو
فتح يتقدم بالهدف الاول وهدف مع انطلاق
الشوط الثاني قاده الدوسري ورفاقه اكثر من
هجمه بحثا عن التعادل
[تصفيق]
الاسباني كريستيانو يظهر مجددا يراوغ
ويسدد والمعيوف بدوره يتصدى للكره
محاولات الهلال استمرت قبل ان ينجح خالد
الغنام في مضاعفه النتيجه باحرازه هدفا
ثانيا للفتح
الهلال لم يستسلم في محاوله للنجاه من
الخساره وتمكن من تضييق الفارق بهدفا عن
طريق صالح الشهري في الوقت المحتسب بدل
الضائع
الحكم البرتغالي ارطغرل دياز ينهي
المباراه فوز ثمين للفتح وخساره ثانيه
للهلال في البطوله التي يحمل لقبها
نهايه اخبار الرياضه شكرا لكم على حسن
المتابعه وعوده اليك خالد
[موسيقى]
الفلكلور البحري في شرق السعوديه فنون
ارتبط بحياه البحاره ولناخذ يتميز
بالوانها الشعبيه المتعدده المميزه ايضا
بكلماتها ورقصاتها المستوحى من البيئه
البحريه تعبر عن عادات وتقاليد المنطقه
الشرقيه وتمثل قيمه تاريخيه في التراث
البحري
للمنطقه علي اللوبي
[موسيقى]
الفنون البحريه الوان شعبيه ارتبطت بالبحر
منذ القدم تنساب انغامها مع رحلات الصيد
والغوص لتمثل ارثا فنيا يحاكي ما تختزله
البيئه البحريه من عادات وتقاليد تمثل
ثقافه مدن شرق السعوديه
البحاره او النواخذ الاجواء من السفر نقدم
لهم هذا الشيء هذا الفعل اللي هو الفن
الخيالي وفيه فنون وفي الوان كثيره هذا
واحد من الالوان اللي نستقبل فيهم البحاره
او النوافذوا من السفر
جميله تعبر عن المنطقه الشرقيه عن تراثهم
عن اجدادهم كان مهتمين اجدادهم بهالشيء
الجميل لها نمر لها نمق بحري ساحلي جميل
تعبر عن حياتهم الجميله البحريه تتعدد
الوان الفنون البحريه في الساحل الشرقي ما
بين فن الفجري والخماري وغيرها من
الاهازيج الشعبيه التي تستمد كلماتها من
الحان البحري ومغامراته بالنسبه حق
الالوان البحريه داخل منطقه الشرقيه او
لهازيج في منها
الفجيري
والسيفي والبستات الخماري
فنون كثيره يعني تتعدد منها احيانا
المركب انه هو تاخر داخل البحر
عاده الامهات او اللي لها ولد او زوجها
يكون داخل البحر يغنونهم الاغاني هذه اللي
ورايا حاليا الفنان محروس الهاجري كان
يغني كثير عن البحر لو اغاني كثيره
خذيه بحر كل ما تبي اللولو والمرجان بس
يرجع المحبوب طول في السفر كان يحاكي
البحر بشكل كبير
[موسيقى]
في المناسبات توثيقا للفلكلور البحري
وتستحذر الحكايات والقصص والتحديات التي
وثقتها ذكريات البحر لتظل حاضره في ذاكره
ابناء المنطقه الشرقيه من الخبر علي
اللقبي العربيه
يدخل الربيع الفعلي في شهر مارس وفيه يقول
العامه قران الخامس ربيع طامس تفاصيل مع
تقويم
[موسيقى]
ترتبط سلوكياتنا الحياتيه والنفسيه بل
المناخ فنحن لا ناكل ولا نشرب ولا نلبس
ولا نسكن الا على مجرياته فالصيف له ماكله
ومشربه وملبسه وكذلك الشتاء ولا نقيم
منازلنا سواء كان ثابته او متحركه الا على
جهات الشمس ففي الشتاء يرحل الباديه الى
الصحراء والحاضره في منازلهم وفي الصيف
يرحل الباديه من مساكنهم الى حيطانهم
ومزارعهم ويوجد فيها الابار التي يتحلق
فيها الباديه وهي موسم تبادل المنفعه
والتعارف فيما بينهم امر على الديار ديار
ليلى اقبل ذا الجداره وذا الجدار وما حب
الديار شغفن قلبي ولكن حب من
سكنت ديارا
[تصفيق]
مع دخول موسم الربيع الفعلي في شهر مارس
ينتشر الربيع ويتمايز نبته وهو مرحله
جراند خامس والذي يقال فيه جراند خامس
ربيعا طامس ولهذا تسمن المواشي وسميت
العقربه الثالثه والاخيره بعقرب الدسم
نتيجه لهذا والعام ما يسمونه بموسم صياح
النبات وهو الموسم التي تبكي وتصيح فيها
الطيور حزنا على فراق الربيع الا وقد
هاجني فزددت شوقا بكاء حمامتين تجاوبان
تجاوبتا بلحن اعجمي على غصنين من غرب
وباني
[موسيقى]
افدى مراسل العربيه باقتحام قوات
اسرائيليه خاصه مخيم جنين في الضفه
الغربيه اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي قتل اربعه
فلسطينيين في المخيم بينهم منفذ عمليه
حواره
بولندا تعلن تزويدك بعشر دبابات اضافيه
هذا الاسبوع
21/22 مارس 2023
ازمه السلطان السلطتين في الكويت تستمر
فوق جلسه البرلمان ونواب يصفون تعطيل
الجلسات بالعبث
رياض تبدا رحله التقييم نحو اكسبو 2020
تعلن عن مشروع وراث ثاني مشاريعها السكنيه
في الرياض
20013 الف مستفيد
انطلاق المنتدى الدولي للترفيه في الرياض
مختصون من انحاء العالم يناقشون مستقبل
القطاع والتحديات
[موسيقى]